basically anywhere there are people that
want to be hurt or want to get something
off their chest I bring mobile suit to
them and give them the option to either
record spits and poetry sing rap the
self express really
[Music]
[Applause]
mobile stew is basically a recording
studio that I started out of my car when
I was trying to solve a problem and that
problem was equal access to musical
equipment or recording studio young
people from different neighborhoods get
all access pass to do because they bring
mobile suits of people yeah we're gonna
Street break down the bone to the liver
so when I get to the spot I pull over
and crack the trunk get out all the
equipment hook up the microphone on the
mic stand then they see me pull up in
the mix board and I start playing beats
with my sight for hit that you bout to
get into this everyone starts to come
over and wants to express themselves on
the microphone and at the same time that
they're doing that I'm recording it so I
give them a version of what they said
it's like a audible snapshot so there
was this young man that was murdered in
Dorchester there's a whole bunch of
people that are like they really wanted
to get revenge I Drive through a mobile
stool and basically I'm giving them the
option to express themself I kind of
realized that mobile stools and just as
simple as I thought it was it was
de-escalating people and so we're like
this is de-escalating how can we use
this to de-escalate our national crisis
which was cops killing kids
cops particularly killing young black
men
we had the opportunity at that same time
to come together musically which means
mobile student dude the important aspect
of working with the officers and young
people together there's a kind of
different kind of a bond when you know
someone not just as an officer arresting
them or having to see them when
something bad happens right after all
that stuff started happening I started
getting calls from the Boston Public
Schools walking into an elementary
school is a little bit different because
we're talking about a classroom that was
supposed to be the worst class in the
school at the times you know special
needs young people that have been
through some serious trauma and I found
out that almost all the kids in there
were musically inclined they wanted to
be a rapper or a singer or a poet to see
a young person excited about something
good that they're doing and I get to
provide that moment that's was
gratifying to me these guys deserve to
have the opportunity to learn how to
record you know they deserve the ability
to express themselves
this ability to get yourself hurt even
if it's just a whole neighborhood in
that moment makes people feel like
valued that's something like that comes
to them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]